und der trend hallo kriegst du und zwar
weil die frage waren sich ist auf der
neuen cd und welche features gemacht
hast weil die leute von geradezu mehr
wird an den leuten du hast die gemacht
wird
oder welt muss verfasst aber
ich würde das ja aber interessieren
darunter auch mitarbeiter
also ich habe viele features auf dem
neuen album es gibt zwei verschiedene
versionen eine mit 20 songs oder 19
sondern mit 28 songs da sind features
drauf vielleicht die der wir etwas sagen
cassandra steen zb
in paris ist da drauf ich habe vor ein
paar wochen auch mit flächen song
aufgenommen für sein neues album
irgendwie nämlich mache immer wieder
auch songs mit anderen leuten wenn du
das nicht mitkriegt dann liegt das einen
medien und nicht an mir das album kommt
am 9 april raus
daher ist er an und findet 10 features
auf den markt